I'm joking or not you tell me I'm not
joking I'd rather do it on camera no no
no no if it's on camera we're not doing
an interview why we'll explain why how
do you feel about that influence that
you have you better be careful we're
coming for your children there buddy
about marish Nation yes I'm going to do
you're going to resign yeah I'm going
I've been answering your question you
answer mine it's actually not my job to
answer your
questions thank God for talk TV is not
only the home of common sense it's the
only place where you get the
truth
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
[Music]
TV tonado appears Morgan uncensored
police sa this weekend's controversial
Pro Palestine March in London will go
ahead Douglas Murray is one of the most
influential and scathing commentators on
the Israeli side of his impassion debate
tonight he joins me from the Gaza border
but our conversation was dramatically
interrupted the comparison between Hamas
and the Nazis is insufficient and I
sorry there's an
incoming uh
[Music]
incoming from the news building in
London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored good evening London welcome
to Pi Morgan uncensored Saturday is arm
jce day and Veterans Day in the United
States every year on the 11th Hour of
the 11th day of the 11th month there is
silence it's a moment for mournful
reflection and for gratitude to the many
millions of people who sacrificed their
lives in the first world war and War
since this year war is on all of our
minds and with bitter irony it's putting
Palestinian supporters on a collision
course with many British people tens of
thousands of pro Palestine protesters
will March through London on armest to
day the Prime Minister RI sunak says
that that's unacceptable the Israeli
president on this show yesterday joined
calls for the march to be banned it's a
atrocious and
hypocritic and I call upon all decent
human beings to object to the March and
ban it because the symbol of that day is
a symbol of Victory and it's it's a
symbol of doing good because when you
fight evil sometimes you have to fight
you have to f fight evil in order to
uproot
evil well I'll be honest now my initial
Instinct about this March was to agree
that it should be banned November the
11th is a sacred and emotional day
there's plenty of evidence that some of
the people joining these protests have
no respect for our Traditions or our
values yes it's a minority but some have
called for Jihad some have defaced our
monuments some have chanted for the
total eradication of Israel the idea
this could happen on a weekend of
remembrance and respect is frankly
sickening and it risks bringing tensions
to the boil but so does the incend
rhetoric from people like our home
secretary we've seen now tens of
thousands of people take to the streets
following the massacre of Jewish people
the single largest loss of Jewish life
since the Holocaust chanting for the
Erasure of Israel from the map to my
mind there's only one way to describe
those marches they are hate marches now
you see I don't think they are hate
marches I think many of the people
taking part believe they're Marching for
peace for an Armistice there are some
there clearly who are hateful but we
already have laws against violence
against inciting hatred and against
supporting terrorists anyone who shows
up with those things in mind should be
swiftly arrested and the police must do
more to do their police work but should
the ugly behavior of a minority and I
believe it is a minority mean we just
throw away our hardfought rights to free
speech this is what Lord Nicholas SS the
grandson of Sir Winston Churchill said
yesterday A lot of people died during
the war to assert freedom I think it
must be allowed to go ahead it's nowhere
near the senat half it's it's it's in
the afternoon it's our thing and most of
those people 90% of those people are not
there to make trouble they're there to
express a deeply held
View really made me think especially
coming from the grandson of Winston
Churchill the man who saved this country
from the
Nazis and of course hearing it from Lord
SS reminded me of the words of his
grandfather which in fact take pride of
place on my dressing room wall here in
the studio of Pierce Morgan un senson
some people's idea of free speech is
that they are free to say what they like
but if anyone says anything back that is
an outrage it's Winston Churchill and
that's really the point here if the
people call calling for a ban on this
March actually agreed with the
protesters they wouldn't have a problem
with it but freedom of speech works both
ways Mr Churchill fought in the first
world war and led us to victory in the
second the many millions who died were
fighting for the Free World We Now live
in and the freedom of speech and
expression that we live by so I respect
the rights of Palestinian supporters to
March peacefully on Armistice Day I just
hope they return that favor and respect
the people who
so that they
can well first tonight author Douglas
Murray has been one of Israel's most
passionate and scathing supporters since
his War Began he's now traveled as a
reporter to the Gaza border from what I
spoke to him earlier tonight and what
turned out to be a very dramatic
interview well I'm joined Now by Douglas
Murray who's on the Gaza border Douglas
let me ask you first of all why have you
felt the need to go
there well I've covered every is Israeli
conflict since the 2006 Lebanon war uh
covered lots of other conflicts as well
and this one is obviously an incredibly
important conflict it's one that is
going to be crucial not just for Israel
but for the region and I like to see
these things firsthand as you know
appears I do and I've I've read your
stuff for many years about these kind of
uh conflicts let me ask you what is your
what's your feeling on the ground there
I know you've been with some of the IDF
what is your feeling about the
motivation for this uh war from the
Israeli side is it revenge is it
something different what what are you
picking
up well it's not Revenge I mean I think
the most obvious thing is I spent part
of today at the uh kibuts of near Oz
this is a Kuts right down the road from
here by the Gaza border where there are
about 400 residents uh 80 of them were
kidnapped on the 7th of October and
another 30 to 40 were murdered and we
went through I went through the remains
of their houses uh saw all the blood
spattered walls and uh went through the
charred remains of that Village that
Community uh that was just one of the
massacre sites I went earlier past the
massacre site of what you remember is
was the music festival uh also near the
the Gaza border uh which was taking
place where so many hundreds of young
people were having a rave and then were
massacred uh raped uh mutilated and
again kidnapped and taken through
through the border into Gaza so uh you
see the remnant of that appalling day
everywhere around here it's very hard to
find a family anywhere in Israel it
hasn't been directly or you know very
closely related to the atrocities of
that day you know 1,400 civilians
slaughtered in one day and thousands
more injured is the sort of thing that
that will have an effect on any society
it would be roughly comparative to say
20,000 people being killed in our own
country um so it's it's a massive thing
it's a massive blow uh in Israel the
whole nation has felt it and of course
people know that there needs to be an
answer to this and I think that's well
you can hear behind me as I'm speaking
some of that answer the Crump of
artillery shells and uh uh uh missiles
from the air it seems and you can see
some of that rising over the Border
behind me you talked about
proportionality in this conflict being
absurd I've talked a lot about what is
proportionate and I I struggled to think
of what a proportionate response is to
the barbarism of those Terror attacks um
you know there is a view and maybe you
share this view but there is a view I
think Ben Shapiro said this to me when I
interviewed him that there there should
be no limit on the response that Israel
has it's not about proportion it's not
about you kill one of us we kill one of
you this is about a war specifically
designed to eliminate Hamas and they
will do what it takes
yes well I mean remember that the one of
the heads of hamz said only a few days
ago uh uh from uh the comfort of his
foreign residents because remember the
heads of hamz don't live among their
peoples they uh they've been made
billionaires by taking an international
aid for years now uh but one of the
heads of hamz said uh the other day we
will keep doing October the 7th again
and again and again so there's
realization in Israel I think that this
is just unlivable you you you can't have
a situation where you have a neighbor
who well won the election in 2006 after
Israel withdrew from the Gaza promptly
killed their fellow Palestinians the
fata members in the Gaza threw them off
buildings and shot them in the back uh
um so Hamas has been ruling Gaza for all
the last one and half decades uh it has
spent all the international Aid money
and much more that has come into it on
its own infr structure of Terror tunnels
its infrastructure of rockets and other
Munitions to throw at Israel and then of
course in enriching its leaders the
place you see behind me could be
Singapore by now and there's a reason it
isn't and it's the leadership of Hamas
and so you know I think that it is
something that people have to realize
that this is not a situation which is
sustainable for Israel and yes the
Israeli uh government is going to be
doing whatever it needs to do to fulfill
its objective of of ridding
uh the Gaza of Hamas uh how easy or
difficult a job that is is another
question but uh it's something that is
going on as we speak but in terms of the
the moral quandry which I've been
feeling and it's not about Israel
wanting to eliminate Hamas I completely
agree with that mission statement and
certainly there's no chance of any peace
when you have a terror group in charge
of Gaza in the way that they've now
completely established themselves to be
with no limits and just a desire to
eradicate Israel and as many Jewish
people as they can kill so just park
that to one side I concur with the
mission statement but it is incredibly
difficult just on a human level to see
because we know the civilian population
in Gaza is half children to see the
sheer numbers of kids who are being
killed by the Israeli uh Onslaught
that's come back against Hamas what do
you feel about that on a human level
what should we all be feeling about that
the first thing is the first thing is
should those deaths really be attributed
to the Israeli side um we saw the other
day the BBC and other media uh reported
that the people who were lying dead on
the street on one of the main routs
through Gaza was alleged to be a um a
massacre carried out by Israelis it
turned out wasn't the case at all uh it
was hamad's massacring Palestinians
fleeing South as the Israelis had
recommended they do um so the question
in a way that you ask I would say
there's an answer to which is who
exactly is responsible for these deaths
um if you do hamaz does uh decide to uh
build bunkers and put rockets on them
and then put hospitals on top of them
who exactly is responsible for that uh
is it the Israelis in their response or
is it Hamas for doing that uh if you do
decide as Hamas has done uh to use all
of these billions of dollars of
international Aid to build tunnels where
you can hide uh among other things uh
the the kidnapped U uh Israelis um who's
responsible for for the the strikes that
happen as a result and any civilian
deaths is it the Israelis or is it Hamas
who has been holding the Palestinian
peoples of the Gaza hostage for the last
15 years and more again I repeat this
point you know a lot of what has been
said about this seems to suggest that
Hamas has no responsibility for this you
know if you if if you went into your
neighbor's house ransacked it raped your
neighbors killed some of them took
others into captivity and then somebody
said uh that's not on I'm going to do
something in retaliation to that uh you
would bear the cost of that you'd bear
the price for that the Israelis have the
right to respond uh to such an atrocity
and I'm I'm rather surprised or at least
I'm not surprised in a way I'm
disappointed as ever by the number of
commentators in the UK and elsewhere who
seem who always use times like this to
say things like we've got to we've got
to you know this is a time for judicious
voices this is a time for calm and much
more I do always wonder if those people
would say the same or feel the same if
it was a bit closer to their own home
you know if it wasn't a Kuts down the
road uh like the one I was in earlier
that had been attacked but you know
Village after Village in the south of
England uh I don't think we'd be hearing
those same voices I think there's a very
particular standard that the Israelis
are held to I think it's an unfair
standard it's an unequal standard it's
an intolerable standard for the Israelis
but when people say you know you've just
got to sort of live with this uh the
Israelis quite rightly will be saying
well we don't see quite why we
do the comparison between Hamas and the
Nazis is insufficient and I sorry
there's an
incoming uh
incoming
[Music]
we're here good morning
everybody hope you're well thanks for
joining us you're watching the
independent republic of Mike gra right
here on talk TV welcome to Friday night
with Nadine here on prime time we like
to speak to the business people behind
big moments good evening I'm Pi Morgan
uncensored in New York City very
impressive well
played I'm 3 days into the job what have
I done wrong and your face just stared
out
me and you conquer time who wins you do
you know what I love about tour today we
do it all sunak swella
scon are you actually speech writing for
this I'm so rich frankly uh I'm going to
take the side of boozed up Brits against
these pomp you mean you're not going to
support mayor Jose L not stop panding to
the nimes to the naysayers and The
National Society for the preservation of
the habitat of the Lesser spotted new
the problem lies in the bureaucracy it's
almost like they highly paid Consultants
don't really know what they're
doing first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you and we're just asking patients to be
patient with us are we only going to be
trusting sources like meta and Google
and Facebook and ex formly known as
Twitter where is our where is our
unbiased news going to come from Welcome
to the talk it's really great to be back
my Little Darlings kids think all they
have to do is stay at home be silly take
pictures of everything just shut down
Tik Tok then yeah problem problem solved
there you go who's fit as a bunch do him
all right but but he's now middle class
three of us here Tess I nearly have
empathy when I'm speaking to them I know
you're probably going to boot me after
CH
this Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking
living got former PMS all over the joint
saying things the last few days we have
indeed yeah great first show you having
fun oh a ton of fun King PE and King
Cube I think there's only room for one
king man you know what I'm saying just
cuz they're skin folk don't mean they're
kin folk when I say I am God you think
I'm joking or not you tell me I'm not
joking I'd rather do it on camera no no
no no if it's on camera we're not doing
an interview why we'll explain why how
do you feel about that influence that
you have you better be careful we're
coming for your children there buddy
about Maring Nation yes I'm going to do
I'm you're going to resign I'm going
I've been answering your question you
answer mine it's actually not my job to
answer your
questions thank God for talk TV is not
only the home of common sense it's the
only place where you get the
truth
[Music]
what about this issue around the pro
Palestinian marches and specifically the
one plan for armor to stay here in
London on Saturday do you think it
should go
ahead well uh my own view is that it
shouldn't and it shouldn't because it's
not because it should be banned but
because it's a grotesque insult to the
British people uh it's a deliberately
provocative day to choose for such a
March it's a deliberately provocative
March as the telegraph showed just
yesterday around half of the organizers
of the March are themselves linked with
Hamas uh which isn't at all surprising
we have Hamas commanders after all who
live in London very safely often on
welfare um and uh so yes I think it's an
intolerable March it's an intolerable
provocation to the British public and
the British govern government and the
British police by the way who Saturday
after Saturday have been made put up
with unbelievable taunting and abuse uh
from the Marchers uh it's clearly it's
it's very clear by now appears that what
is happening is that every week the the
crowds are pushing and seeing if they
can push the police further and further
harder and harder and be more and more
provocative and they're managing to do
that uh but this is culminating this
weekend and here here's the thing I
don't think and I certainly read and
hear that large numbers of the British
public are just just not going to put up
with this uh the let me pick you up on
that diverted away from whiteall but
right but let me pick you up on that cuz
it's interesting cuz you like me have
been a very vocal you know and
passionate defender of free speech and
we know that that includes sure that you
have to accept that other people you may
vly disagree with have a right to free
speech you know Christopher Hitchin some
that you and I both admire this isn't
this no I'm going to come to my question
but Christopher hitchon said the only
thing that should be upheld all cast
them without qualification is a right of
free expression because if that goes
then so do all other the claims of right
as well now what was interesting to me
I've been on a bit of a journey this
week about what I really think about
this and Nicholas SS actually said
something that really made me sit up and
take notice and changed my mind about it
actually because he's Churchill's
grandson he's a conservative um and he
said strongly yesterday that he thinks
the March should be allowed to go ahead
because the very freedoms that the
people on Armistice Day who we honor who
gave their lives uh in the wars they did
so to preserve the freedoms of people
like those Marchers the ones who are not
being violent the ones who are not
showing proam stuff that they have a
right to to
protest well well we we we'll try to
single those two things out for a second
uh first of all I don't regard Nicholas
SS as a sort of hereditary uh uh uh
inheritor of the mantle of Churchill
just because he happens to be his
grandson um uh and besides what you
quoted from Christopher earlier he would
never have uh said that that right
extended to supporting Terror groups I
mean we're in a total quandry in the UK
as you know and it's a Despicable
quandry to be in we host them as Leaders
we have a deputy prime minister former
deputy prime minister of Iran living in
Harrow we've been at the center of
allowing these people to be in our
country and indeed to plot Terror from
our country for years so it's always a
bit Rich to hear the British I think
lecturing others about being an unsound
part of of the International Security uh
Community as for the actual marches look
um I'm afraid that the rules on this are
very very clear um you are not allowed
to glorify Terror or call for Terror on
the streets of Britain and that existed
before the 2006 terrorism act banned
glorification and it certainly exists
now uh if you stand on the Streets of
London Calling for Jihad you are calling
for Terror and that is actually a place
where free speech is at its limit and is
no longer permissible it's the same with
for instance calls for in on the London
tubes remember we had a touch of in on
the London tubes a few years ago so
again calling for in is something that
you're not allowed to do in the UK call
for murder you're not allow you're not
allowed to let me finish one other case
you're not allowed uh to stand on the
Streets of London and call for the
murder of Jews or any other minority and
yet people have been getting away with
this afterday and and are the police
arresting people no no they're not the
police last week said said we're
outnumbered right so that is a key point
the police have said met commissioner
samart roley said the laws created by
parliament are clear there is ABS no
absolute power to ban protest therefore
there will be a protest this weekend but
the laws are also there to stop people
brazenly supporting terrorism so if
people were to use a pramas banner or
chant pramas uh a sentiment that would
be against the current law of this
country and the police should take
action that's a different issue though
it is it is but it's not being police
not being police I understand so on that
I can agree with you the police need to
enforce the existing laws however there
will be a large they're not going to
because they're outnumbered they're out
you and I can agree that that that's
wrong but that shouldn't mitigate the
rights well don't you think that matters
hang on don't you think that matters no
it does matter that means that we have a
rule of law but it's not able to be
policed what's the point of having a law
if you can't police well I agree with
you but I also think that the the there
are a large number of those protesters
who genuinely are in their eyes
protesting for peace and they're Pro
Palestinian and they have a view in the
way that I disagree with that I disagree
with that and I'll tell you one reason
why the crowds in question are 100 times
larger than the number of people who
came out when hundreds of thousands of
people were being killed in Yemen they
are aund times larger than the number of
people who came out when Bashar al-
Assad killed hundreds of thousands of
people in Syria seems to me that the
people in question own care if one side
in the particular conflict happens to
involve the Israelis very excited but
they're allowed to so I don't well
they're allowed to absolutely and that
and we can make judgments about them but
I would not presume by any means that
what you're talking about are pro peace
people they're anti-israeli that's it
well but they're allowed to be
anti-israeli I think that's the point
they're not allow sure they're allowed
to be anti if you allowed to be in that
case I suppose we have to allow people
to be anti- other nations as well I mean
Britain was founded at the same sorry
Israel sorry was founded in the same
year within the year of Pakistan maybe
we should allow large protests of
hundreds of thousands of people to go
around the Streets of London protesting
that Pakistan doesn't have a right to
exist or right to defend itself we
should I don't think it's a good a good
president what hang on I don't think you
have a right to say that Israel doesn't
exist if you want the extermination of
all people in Israel that is that is a
criminal offense however if you are
literally as I said well it doesn't seem
to be a criminal offense P it doesn't
seem agree on that we're clearly in a
position we're clearly in a position
where they're not policing the law
otherwise we wouldn't have all of these
videos of people inciting violence on
the streets but Douglas you and I can
agree that the police need to enforce
existing law I I don't there's no
dispute between us on that and they
should be doing that a lot more but we
also I think have to surely look at the
people who are genuinely there in a
nonviolent manner of which there are
many these are massive protests I think
back to the protest for example against
Donald Trump when he came to London
against America because he was the
president we allowed that to happen I
didn't necessarily agree with them but
we allowed them to happen you know I
remember Madonna saying we should blow
up the White House a woman's March in
Washington that happened and people
accepted that yeah but yeah but here's
here's here's a very important point on
that Pi Madonna almost certainly so far
as I know has no military capability
behind her so when Madonna says I'd like
to blow up the White House it's a piece
of stupid rhetoric uh from a pop star um
when you've just had the largest
Massacre of since the Holocaust and you
have Hamas supporters and others
marching through London Calling for it
to happen again that does matter because
there is a capability so there is a
difference isn't there well there is but
I don't think that all of these
protesters are pramas and the difference
the difference is you have a large
artillery behind yeah but you wouldn't
you don't honestly think they're all
pramas these
people well I I I think that anyone who
for instance chants things like from the
river to the sea is is in fact yes but
they're not all doing that or is
criminally ignorant oh well they are I
mean there's masses of videos of them
Maring past Westminster Abby last week
saying exactly that yeah but they're not
all doing Pastor s winon church I watch
the videos and there are lots of people
and some who aren well here's a
challenge okay well here's a challenge
Pi if you decided to go on some kind of
March and in week one you discovered
that you had the BNP along your side
calling for instance for the murder of
all black people would you not wonder
whether or not you should go on week two
and would you not drop out by about week
three I'd have thought so I would that's
a good question uh and yes I would but
that doesn't actually right so we can
tell something about the Marchers well
you can tell that you can say that you
have a view your own opinion is they
shouldn't be marching alongside these
other people however they are still
entitled in a free Democratic country
like USS look I I don't have absolute
opinions on this I I just think it's a
really interesting test of how far Free
Speech goes and I do feel un interesting
test if I could
the the interesting test if I can say so
Pi is there are limits to this in fact
you are not allowed to glorify the
murder of people on the streets of
Britain you are not allowed to be a
member of a prescribed terrorist group
in Britain but I return to the point I
made at the start we allow it I repeat
we have Hamas commanders living in the
UK who take welfare in the UK and use it
to commit Terror why are they not locked
up because we have laws that we don't
pursue we have criminal charges that we
don't use the person in particular I'm
thinking of Muhammad saala got British
citizenship you're meant to sign a form
saying you're a person of good character
to become a British citizen can you say
that somebody who was a former military
commander of Hamas in the West Bank is
quote a person of good character I'd say
not so again like the police like many
other people the border control in the
UK doesn't enforce the law doesn't care
to do so so and I repeat there is a
serious problem with this in the UK
Israel as you can see tonight can look
after itself I wonder if Britain can say
the same yeah listen I understand that
point you've also said it will have to
be counted if the March goes ahead
because the British public shouldn't
have to put up with it but what does
that mean in reality you're not
endorsing people to go and confront them
are you no no not at all um I'm I would
suggest that if the Senate half for
instance comes under attack there should
be a peaceful ring of people around the
Senate have to protect it as with other
monuments and I think that that's what
many people will do I hope they do so
peacefully but as this goes on and as
the pro provocations grow and grow I'm
afraid I'm very very afraid from what's
going to happen this weekend coming in
the UK personally I think it's safer in
Israel these days than it is in central
London certainly for
Jews let's talk um given you're over
there right now uh what what concerns me
about what Israel is doing is not their
efforts to get rid of Hamas but because
of the particular nature of Hamas
embedded themselves among civilian
populations with the masses amounts of
Civilian casualties that will inevitably
come and that figure will grow and grow
and grow are we not as Barack Obama
warned are we not creating here uh just
an opportunity for far greater
radicalization of all those young
Palestinians who watch their loved ones
get killed why would we imagine that at
the end of all this they're going to
want to do anything other than to become
a new version of Hamas in wanting to
exact revenge for what happened to their
families well two things one is if you
just follow the logic of what Barack
Obama said then you just shouldn't do
anything uh if you're Israel you should
be attacked and just sit back and say
great we'll wait for the next one um but
the second and more important thing is
your question supposes that there is a
sort of peaceful Palestinian population
in the Gaza who would love a two-state
solution and then a few bad app in hamz
I think that's not true why is it that
when one of the victims of the music
festival a poor young German Jewish girl
uh who it seems was was raped and then
uh brutally uh murdered and taken into
the Gaza naked why was it that you can
find and anyone can find this online a
crowd of ordinary gazans it wasn't hamaz
it wasn't Hamas rally ordinary Garin uh
spitting on her body uh hitting her body
mutilating her body further as it went
down the street does that strike you
peers as a Placid population of peac
niik types who are just desperately
waiting for a two-state solution to be
put back on the table for the millionth
time in the last 70s something years it
doesn't seem like that to me no but
there are over two million people in
Gaza and there weren't two million
people in that video clip there were a
few hundred so I I don't like to make
yeah a few hundred at random a few
hundred at random and did you see anyone
in it saying hey guys stop we're not
meant to mutilate the bodies of of girls
or rape them in public no I didn't see
that but but then what you're really
articulating correct me if I'm wrong
here but isn't what you're articulating
really an endorsement of collective
punishment where you assume they're all
guilty no and if they don't stand up to
Hass they're also guilty and that's
where people have a problem I think with
the moral line here which is if you hold
if you hold all the Garin equally
responsible then is that not Collective
punishment which is illegal well first
of all first of all um there are there
is some responsibility for peoples in
the Gaza um if you elect elect Hamas and
uh and they kill uh fata and then they
remain in power for all of the years
afterwards um I'm afraid that there is
some uh responsibility of the people in
that situation you know when the Germans
U um had Adolf Hitler come to power and
voted for him uh we in Britain took the
view that the German people were
responsible in some way so I'm not for
Collective punishment per se but nor am
I I for this idea that there is
something unique going on in the Israeli
Gaza context that we and Britain
couldn't understand there is one UN in
our own history very similar things but
there is one unique thing which is that
the population of Gaza is pretty unique
and that nearly half of the population
are children that is a unique situation
no I'll tell you what's unique about the
population of Gaza it's the only
population in the world where people
routinely claim Israelis are committing
genocide but which has a population boom
all of the time I mean that strikes me
as being quite an interesting thing
about the Gaza um but as for as for the
moral quy I want to make a very very
important point if I can say so on this
which is you know people quite often
abuse history and they say things all
the time right about the only thing
anyone from history knows is about the
naris here's something I can tell you
with absolute certainty uh peers having
not just seen some of the results of
what Hamas did on the ground here in
Israel a few weeks ago but having
watched the videos of the unedited
footage uh which I was one of the
journalists um was sadly allowed to see
the other day I can tell you one thing
the comparison between Hamas and the
Nazis is insufficient and I sorry
there's an
incoming uh
incoming get safe
Douglas come come
come
are you okay
Douglas it came from the other direction
so okay anyhow we're okay are you okay
um let's let's just yeah yeah yeah it's
fine it's sor sorry it was it was a it
was a rocket coming it looked like it
was just going to land on us here which
way was that rocket coming from is it
coming from Gaza or from
Israel yes seem to be coming from Gaza
so yeah it's fine it's okay it's been
happening all day um let me just before
we go on Douglas Atman how does that
make you how does that make you feel
what just happened
there I mean it's uh I'm I'm a little
used to it I was in Ukraine last year
and was in kerson and Odessa and mikol
and when the Russians were shelling it
so I'm a little used to it
um uh but just if I can just finish this
point you know this soor there's a lot
of banging going on but anyway we'll
keep going um well if you need if you
need to stop Doug we understand no no
don't worry if we need to stop I'll I'll
I'll run to the shelter I show you um
the the thing that stri struck me you
know appears about seeing the 7th of
October footage was that
um even the Nazis were actually ashamed
of what they did you know SS battalions
who spent their days shooting Jews in
the back of the head and pushing them
into TR uh into trenches had to get very
very drunk in the evening to uh uh
forget what they had done uh the Nazi
High command famously had to sort of get
around the problem of soldier morale
because the soldiers knew this wasn't
exactly what their lives were meant to
look like either I tell you one very big
difference if you look at the footage
the raw footage and I really hope people
don't on a wider scale have to view what
I viewed the other day um if they see it
they will see something that is at least
as barbaric as what the Nazis did but
here's the difference they did it with
Glee they were deeply proud you see
people um uh trying you know taking the
head off a young Israeli man with a sh
Shel and then uh calling their parents
back in Gaza and telling them Father
father I've killed two Jews with my 10
Jews in my own hands get mother on the
phone I want to show tell her how great
a job her son has done you know I I come
back to this thing I'm not exaggerating
this it's very very interesting and
people need to realize you had this
situation with uh with the Nazis where
they also were a genocidal anti-semitic
organization but they tried to cover
their crimes up are actually proud of
them and they've said they will do them
until the whole world is clear clear of
Jews yeah so I suggest we take that
seriously and I think that Israel is
taking it seriously I hope they continue
to take it seriously but I think the
world should take it seriously and that
includes Britain and when I hear British
journalists British commentators and
British politicians lecturing the
Israelis on what they should do I think
I'm sorry this shows a failing in our
country it shows that we in Britain
cannot enforce our laws we don't even
enforce our borders in Britain it's us
that is the weak Link in the
International Security chain on this not
Israel Douglas how does this war end
Netanyahu said yesterday that he sees
the at the end of this uh Gaza falling
under Israel occupation for an
indefinite period now there are many
people in Israel who absolutely want
Netanyahu out and hold him accountable
for what happened on October the 7th in
this terms of the failing of defense and
security he's deeply unpopular now
amongst his own people but this whole
idea that you somehow reconcile the
75-year conflict which has blown up into
Warfare Time and Time Again by Israel
ending up as a completely occupying
force that seems to me utterly untenable
yeah well I I think that I mean look it
is it's too early to tell I would just
say this and I've said this before but
Israel is one of the only countries in
the world that's never allowed to win a
conflict uh it has been left with this
question of the Palestinians in the West
Bank the question of the Palestinians in
Gaza it's been left with this for years
and by the way I say left with it
because remember the jordanians could
solve the problem in the West Bank
immediately by taking the Palestinians
there in or taking some kind of control
they don't want to the the Egyptians I
have friends who were born in Gaza when
it was owned by the Egyptians run by the
Egyptians Egyptians could solve the Gaza
problem tomorrow by allowing the gazans
into Egypt or taking control of the Gaza
El nobody wants the Palestinians people
and there's this endless endless mistake
that is being made and it has been made
all my lifetime certainly which is that
there's this unsolved problem but it it
is the job of the Israelis to solve it
what is happening behind me is a
demonstration of the fact that it is an
insoluble problem that the Israelis keep
being told to solve Gaza ever since the
Israelis left it in 2005 could have
become Singapore it could have become a
thriving place but Hamas didn't want
that they wanted to turn it into a place
instead of building upwards they built
downwards instead of building great
buildings they buil built great tunnels
this is a tragedy for the Palestinian
peoples but it's one that has been
brought on them by groups like Hamas who
do not want a settlement in this war
Douglas Murray uh so powerful to talk to
you there on the Gaza border and I'm
glad that you came through what was a
pretty scary moment in the middle of
that interview and I appreciate you
coming back and continuing interview as
if nothing had happened quite remarkable
to witness after sa from the safety of
my my London Studio but I do appreciate
it and stay safe out there that's right
will'll do very good to see you peers
thanks
dolas we're here good morning everybody
hope you're well thanks for joining us
you're watching the independent republic
of Mike gra right here on talk TV
welcome to Friday night with Nadine here
on prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored in
New York City very impressive well
play I'm 3 days into the job what have I
done wrong and your face just stared out
at me me and you conquer time who wins
you do you know what I love about tour
today we do it all sunak sella
scon are you actually speech rating for
R she sunak I'm so rich frankly uh I'm
going to take the side of boozed up
Brits against these pomp you mean you're
not going to support mayor Jose L
not stop panding to the nimes to the
naysayers and The National Society for
the preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's almost like there
highly paid concerns don't really know
what they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you and we're just asking patients to be
patient with us are we only going to be
trusting sources like meta and Google
and Facebook and X form you known as
Twitter where is our where is our
unbiased news going to come from welcome
to the talk it's really great to be back
my Little Darlings kids think all they
have to do is stay at home be silly take
pictures of everything just shut down
Tik Tock then yeah problem problem
solved you go who's fit as a buter do
him all right but but he's now middle
class us here Tess I nearly have empathy
when I'm speaking to them I know know
you're probably going to W
me this is talk
TV
[Music]
welcome back to P Morgan on sensor PL
will fall out from the Israel war is
sewing division on both sides of the
Atlantic here in the UK labor MP Imran
Hussein has quit the shadow cabinet
because his leader sakir St quite
possibly our next prime minister won't
back a ceasefire Democrats in the US are
turning on President Biden over his
support for Israel Republicans meanwhile
are divided on how far the US should go
to back its Ally whether funding should
be tied to to its aid for Ukraine to
discuss all this I'm joined by
Republican senator ran Paul author of
the new book deception the great coid
cover up Senator great to speak to you
again it's been a while great to see you
pierce and I'm glad you're uncensored
now I guess we can say anything we want
right you can absolutely say whatever
you want and you will not be edited
senators are you far away um I want to
start uh we've just been uh discussing
on the show uh with Douglas Murray uh
these protests and in particular a mass
protest plann for London
on Saturday on armist day Veterans Day
of course in America and a huge debate
has erupted about whether this this
March should be banned it's now being
decided by the Metropolitan Police it
will go ahead uh the organizers said
they won't go nearby senat half the
Prime Minister Richi sunak has said he's
very against this March but he also
understands that Free Speech means that
they're entitled to do it even if we
find it distasteful what do you think of
this you know I think the answer to
Despicable speech or speech you disagree
with is more speech uh I think combating
ugly things with uh better ideas and
with useful arguments is much better
than Banning speech now there there are
some parameters though I mean you can't
in the United States you can't uh say
we're going to go shoot up a school or
we're going to blow up a military base
there are things you can't say but for
the most part if you're going to stand
up and say we think the Palestinians are
deprived and in despair and we think
it's israeli's fault um one that's not
anti-Semitism that's a political point
of view it's a it's a point of view I
disagree with but I would never want to
censor it because that's not the kind of
country I want to live in and I already
have complaints in my own country about
censoring speech with regard to the
ideas that I put forward in my book
right I'm going to come to that um
because you're right I mean I think a
lot of censorship went on during the co
pandemic and I'm not entirely blameless
myself actually in terms of the way I
conducted that debate early on um let me
talk to you first about Israel and this
war with Hamas a lot of debate again
about where the line is in terms of
proportionality do you think there is a
line in terms of Israel's
response I'm afraid you froze up there
if we could repeat the question for me
please my apologies I'll ask you again
let me start by asking you about Israel
and this war with Hamas a lot of debate
raging about what is a proportionate
response by Israel many people saying on
the Israeli side they don't think there
should be any proportion to the response
they should do whatever it takes to get
rid of Hamas where do you sit on this
debate you know I was horrified to see
the kids at the concert killed I have
three boys that have all gone to music
concerts in the US and I can't imagine
people showing up in Jeeps with
automatic weapons and just mowing down
innocent unarmed people going house to
house killing women children mothers
father s so just the horror of the
senseless violence that came from
Hamas I think there's a difference also
in that Hamas uh targeted civilians now
there is some question of the civilians
who do die and will die in Gaza what are
the repercussions of that I don't fault
um Israel for saying we've got to wipe
out this Menace Hamas and we can't live
this way with them killing our civilians
I don't in any way condemn that but
there is a point at which um the
incidental or accident ental uh killing
of civilians in the incursion in Gaza
will backfire this has been the same
thing that I've pointed out throughout
the world when we drone some goat hurder
in in Africa do we get rid of terrorism
or do we make all of his family uh Angry
enough to become terrorists themselves
so there is that I also think that
someone has to be saying over and over
again what would come with peace what
would come with the Palestinians
choosing uh to absolve and to to
denounce violence and to recognize
Israel what kind of prosperity would
come from that I don't think we say that
enough because I think in saying that
there may well be some Palestinians
somewhere they're listening in Gaza or
the West Bank that say I want to be that
leader that brings peace to my community
and prosperity to Gaza by renouncing
violence but I don't think we say enough
what would come the good things that
would come by renouncing violence yeah I
mean prime minister Netanyahu has now
come out and said that he sees Israel in
definitely occupying Gaza at the end of
this war but that seems to me to be
probably the very worst thing he should
be saying if he wants to bring
Palestinians to a place of any hope at
the end of
this yeah you know Israel has to decide
what they have to decide for their own
security but there is a downside to an
occupation there's a downside to
remaining there because the question is
how much of uh the Palestinian people in
Gaza are with Hamas and how much are not
will long-term occupation convince more
people who are not yet aligned with
Hamas to become aligned with Hamas all
these questions have to be sorted
through and none of this is to say they
can't and shouldn't defend themselves
but there there are actions and
reactions you know for every action
there's a reaction and so you have to
think these things through and I think
while that's going on still someone
needs to be dangling the carrot of you
know if the if if if they were to
renounce violence in Gaza think of all
the gulf shums around them Saudi Arabia
and all the very wealthy countries that
could help them but they've been
prevented from helping them because the
worry is that there'll be missiles and
bombs and they shoot missiles into
Israel if that could stop and there
could be a legitimate Authority in Gaza
you know I think the the possibility for
Prosperity Way you know unimaginably
beyond where we are now and to get rid
of the Despair and poverty would be
something that maybe we can find
reasonable people that that will appeal
to
[Music]
we're here good morning everybody hope
you're well thanks for joining us you're
watching the independent republic of
Mike gra right here on talk TV welcome
to Friday night with Nadine here on
prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening I'm Pi Morgan uncensored in New
York City very impressive well played
I'm 3 days into the job what have I done
wrong and your face just starred out at
me me and you conquer time who wins you
do you know what I love about tour today
we do it all sunak sella
scon are you actually speech rating for
the I'm so rich frankly uh I'm going to
take the side of boozed up Brits against
these pomp you mean you're not going to
support mayor Jose
Lou stop panding to the nimes to the
naysayers and The National Society for
the preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's almost like they highly
paid Consultants don't really know what
they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you and we're just asking patients to be
p patient with us are we only going to
be trusting sources like meta and Google
and Facebook and X form you known as
Twitter where is our where is our
unbiased news going to come from Welcome
to the talk it's really great to be back
my Little Darlings kids think all they
have to do is stay at home be silly take
pictures of everything just shut down
Tik Tock then yeah problem problem
solved there you go fit as a bunch of
him all right but but he's now middle
class here Tess I nearly have empathy
when I'm speaking to him I know now
you're probably going to Boop me off
show
this Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking for
living got former PMS all over the joint
saying things the last few days we have
indeed yeah great first show having fun
oh a ton of fun King PE and King Cube I
think there's only room for one king man
you know what I'm saying
just cuz they're skin folk don't mean
they're kin folk when I say I am God you
think I'm joking or not you tell me I'm
not joking I'd rather do it on camera no
no no no if it's on camera we're not
doing an interview why we'll explain why
how do you feel about that influence
that you have you better be careful
we're coming for your children there
buddy about Maring Nation yes I'm going
to do you're going to Res I'm going I've
been answering your question you answer
mine it's actually not my job to answer
your
questions thank God for TV is not only
the home of common sense it's the only
place where you get the
[Music]
truth there's a lot of debate over here
and indeed everywhere outside of America
about your presidential race you've not
endorsed any of the Republican
candidates yet you've seen a number of
them um you know people outside of
America are looking at America and going
is is this really the best you can do a
rematch of trump Biden one guy in his
80s who can barely string a sentence
together another one facing 100 criminal
indictments it's like is that it uh what
do you say to that well you know I
haven't endorsed yet because I haven't
decided yet whether I'm going to run or
not you know I ran in 2016 maybe I
should throw my hat in I don't think
it's going that great for everybody else
and nobody seems to be coming forward
Trump still seems to be getting more
votes than all the rest combined so
maybe they need somebody new in the race
uh that's kidding for the most part I do
think that uh the race of Biden versus
Trump there are a lot of people who
think uh you know they'd like another
choice but um right now I think that's
what the choices will be and who do you
think will win if it is Trump
Biden I think the extraordinary
extraordinary thing is is the more that
they've indicted Trump and the more that
these prosecutions are seen as
persecutions and is seen as you know
where they go back and change the law
because statute of limitation expired
years ago and they changed the law just
to prosecute him it's done by political
Das who are campaigning on the fact that
they're going after Trump it's only
brought his numbers up and there was a
poll recently that had Trump ahead in
five Battleground States so I think that
it's difficult to imagine Trump winning
but it's also difficult to uh imagine
anything more unfair they could do to
him and also how pitiful the performance
of Biden has been and how frail and
detached that he looks in doing his job
that it worries people that he's still
able and has enough VI and vigor to
actually be the President right let's
tell you a book deception the great coid
coverup this is all about of course the
coronavirus pandemic at the heart of
your book you be you believe there was a
great deception not just on the American
people but actually on the on the
world there's probably never been more
actual factual data to show a deception
in this case than any other we have a
treasure Trove of hundreds and hundreds
of private emails where Anthony fouchy
and the scientists around him say my
goodness the virus looks manipulated my
goodness we know they're doing gain of
function research in that lab and yet
publicly they were saying the opposite
it became so bad that it actually
intersects with the question of
censorship for over a year and a half
Facebook took down any mention that the
virus might have come from the lab in
public Anthony fouchy said how dare you
the NIH has never ever funded gain of
function research in wuan but it turns
out in private he readily was
acknowledging that yes they had funded
it and yes it did look like the most
likely explanation was that it came from
the lab meanwhile the public journals
that he commissioned the scientists that
were on his payroll to write these
articles were saying no way you're
you're crazy or it's a conspiracy theory
if you believe this but I would say now
that uh it's sort of evenly split in the
scientific Community if not trending in
the direction of believing
uh that the evidence is uh indicates
that it came from the lab are we any
better prepared as a world for another
pandemic do you
think no because the the best thing we
can do is prevention uh once the
pandemic comes out I don't think
anything that we did uh short of the
vaccine altered the course of the uh
disease and in some ways since the
vaccine didn't stop transmission I think
it helped reduce death in the targeted
population but didn't reduce
transmission but as far as prevention
could quit creating these super viruses
think about it there are scientists who
say well Ebola it's really deadly to
study it why don't we see if we can make
it aerosolized and transmittable through
the air there are scientists that
believe that that's sort of a death wish
that sort of a gamble with civilization
Ebola kills 50% of the people but it's
transmitted more like AIDS through
bodily fluids and so it's not as
contagious as going through the air what
world would we want the tax dollars the
government tax tax dollars to be going
towards trying to aerosolize a virus
that is deadly well sen Paul you ask a
lot of questions like that in your book
as you have done indeed as a senator in
the last few years and it's been very
impressive to watch you'd make a great
investigative journalist so if you ever
want a new job come and join Piers
Morgan uncensored but for for now thank
you for coming on the show and I really
appreciate it thank you that's it for me
whatever you're up to keep it un sensive
good
night
[Applause]
[Music]